apple just released the brand new apple
watch series 6
and the absolute most important question
people have on their minds
is if they should actually upgrade to it
because it's available to order
right now the answer is actually
different depending on which apple watch
you currently own
right now if you do own one and how
important the new features they just
introduced
are to you now apple also released the
apple watch se
but we'll leave that for another video
so before we go ahead and answer that
question
let me quickly go through everything the
apple announced about the apple watch
series 6
but first be sure to check out our apple
products shirt and our mask
down in the merch shelf below the
biggest change is the new finishes
and this time we have three of them blue
aluminum
product red aluminum and graphite
stainless steel
and we actually just ordered the red
model so subscribe
right now if you want to see us test it
out there's also a couple of
brand new bands which are very
interesting this year
there's the new solo loop band that
lacks any type of clasp or buckle
it's simply one piece that you stretch
and slip over your wrist
and apple actually has you print out a
template that you can wrap around your
wrist
so you can order the perfect band size
there's also a totally unique
braided solo loop band which is made out
of yarn with silicone threads
to keep it stretchy so we're excited to
get our hands on that band
apple did mention some new watch faces
including the gmt face
the chronograph pro face the new memoji
face and
more but it seems like those faces are
available on all
apple watches that support watchos 7
which is available tomorrow by far the
most
important new feature of this series 6
is the new blood oxygen sensor
which uses infrared light to measure
your blood oxygen levels
you can use it by going into the new
blood oxygen app and taking a 15 second
measurement
but what's really great about it is that
it actually takes background readings
every once in a while so we can warn you
if your blood oxygen levels are too low
and it even works while you sleep which
is a huge deal
for those with sleep issues there's also
the new s6 chip
which is said to be more efficient and
20
faster than the previous s5 chip this is
going to help balance out the battery
life
because a pretty huge new feature this
year is that the always on display is
now
2.5 times brighter when outdoors
which was one of the biggest issues that
we had with the apple watch series
5. and then there's also a new sensor
which detects elevation
which can be very useful for hiking now
there are a couple of things that apple
didn't really mention
and those are some spec differences the
new apple watch series 6 can now connect
to the 5 gigahertz wi-fi band instead of
being previously limited
to only 2.4 gigahertz another hidden gem
is that the series 6 comes with the u1
ultraband chip built in
and i have a feeling that apple is going
to announce some great new features
with that chip at next month's event
when they're likely to also announce
the new air tax apple still seems to be
rating the battery life as the same
18 hours as before even though the new
s6 chip
is more efficient probably because of
the brighter always on display
but the main downside this year is that
the apple watch is no longer shipping
with a power adapter in the box
so you actually have to pay an extra 19
if you want to add that to your purchase
and there you go that's basically every
single change with the apple watch
series six
and now let's answer the original
question of whether you should upgrade
or not
like i said before it depends on which
watch you own
right now so i'm going to split them up
into two different groups
the series 4 and the series 5 are in one
group
because they have the updated design
with the curved display
and they have processors which are
noticeably faster than
the older models they also have the
updated sensors
which not only look awesome but they
work better than the ones on the older
watch models
and they also have the ecg feature which
is awesome because
it's already been detecting issues in
people's hearts
and the fall detection has actually
saved lives as well
so props to apple for all of those
changes but between the series 4 and the
series 5
the only real difference that was
noticeable apart from the storage
upgrade
was the always on display and to some
people
that difference was enough to upgrade to
the series 5.
and this year there are more important
differences but in reality
if you already have one of those two
newer apple watches
your experience won't change that much
unless
one of those new features is very very
important to you
for example if blood oxygen monitoring
is something your health requires
then you should absolutely upgrade to
the series 6
even from the series 5. or if the new
wi-fi improvements
or the new altimeter are a big deal to
you or if you think there's great
potential in the u1 ship
and you don't want to have an apple
device without that new chip
so if those things are very important to
you then it's probably worth the upgrade
but if those specific things don't
really matter to you
i also don't think that the processor
upgrade itself is going to be worth it
coming from the series 4 or the 5
because those watches already felt very
quick and snappy the display is going to
look basically the same
and the battery life isn't going to be
drastically different but the brighter
always on display
could be a big deal for you but if you
really just want an apple watch for
working out then the series 6 won't
really make that big of a difference
and also keep in mind that the series 4
and 5
still support the same new bands they
still support the same new watch faces
and they even support the new family
setup feature
which makes it so an apple watch can be
used without an iphone being connected
so from a bang for the buck perspective
i would probably just keep your series 4
or 5 for another year to see what apple
has to offer in the future
especially if they get glucose
monitoring working
now if you still have the apple watch
series 3 then congratulations for
waiting so long
because now is probably the perfect time
to upgrade
it's got a great curved display the
sensors are now
updated and packed with a ton of great
features and you'll notice a massive
difference
going from one of those older watches to
the new series six
so it's definitely worth upgrading now
one thing to keep in mind is that if
glucose monitoring is important to you
or any of the other rumored features and
you're totally happy with your
current watch then it may be a good idea
to just wait another year
and if you're still unsure on whether
you should upgrade or not
we already ordered both the series 6 and
the apple watch sc
and we'll be doing a full comparison as
soon as we get them in so go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe
so you don't miss out on those videos
thanks for watching and we'll see you
in the next one